now that we've introduced mechanical
energy and our potential energy
functions we're describing our systems
differently we talked about States we
talked about the potential energy of
that state we talked about the
mechanical energy of that state remember
we're always referring to a reference
state for our reference potential but in
one dimension what we have is that the
potential energy say in some final state
minus the change in potential energies
from some initial state was that
integral X final of the X component of
our I'm going to put C up there for
conservative force DX and now we can so
the potential energy difference is the
integral of the force with a minus sign
now let's look at a fundamental theorem
of calculus which tells us that anytime
you take the difference of a function
between two endpoints then by definition
that's the derivative integrated with
respect to DX so when we compare these
two pictures this is a math here this is
our physics how we define them that when
we compare these two pictures we see
that we can recover the conservative
force by taking the derivative minus the
derivative of the potential function
here force does not depend on any
reference point and when we
differentiate a constant that's zero so
this is independent of the reference
point and this enables us to when we
think about the potential function and
its first derivative then this tells us
about forces let's look at an example
suppose again we look at our spring
potential where we're talking about the
potential energy function of a spring
we're at our zero point where it was
unstretched was our reference point and
if we plotted this function so let's
plot that function so here is U of X
versus X now we can talk about at any
given point
so suppose we're at a point here
maybe our energy has some fixed value
then the slope at this point is equal to
D u DX and the force is minus that slope
so here you can see that the slope is
positive so the force is negative so I
can write FX like that
so here FX is negative so our actual
force is pointing inward when we're on
this side of the potential function my
slope is negative so the X component of
the force is positive so my force is
pointing everywhere on this side back to
the unstretched length so knowledge of
the potential function also by underst
knowledge of its first derivative gives
us information about the force at any
point any state that the system is in so
when we talk about potential implicitly
we also know what the forces and the
potential function is enough to tell us
what the force is at any point and let's
just check for this simple case this is
minus D u DX when you differentiate that
you get minus K X and we know that's the
spring force so this is why we're subtly
shifting our focus to our state our
function U of X and its first derivative